I want to start by saying
congratulations you're fantastic in the
movie whole movie is great and I'm out
that's all I got thank you so much I
love this entity it's great
um no I have actually a few things that
really want to get through and before we
get into this I as a fan of Bodyguard I
have to ask you do you think there will
be another series or do you think it was
so good like leave it alone I very much
hope there's no the series I think
there's a lot to tell about this
character yeah and and we wanted to
leave a gap before doing another one
because I mean you've seen it you know
what happens this man I think he needs a
break at the end of that and then I'd
quite like to catch up with him a year
and a half down the line and see like
where is he now has he changed since all
those events and what situation is he
gonna be in next complete I like this
answer jumping into this movie you have
such great scenes with Taryn in the film
how much is that in the rehearsal
process figuring it all out and how much
is it sort of you know in the moment on
set with Dexter you know what I mean
majority well we did a little bit
rehearsal before but majority of it as
on set on the day and that's the joy of
Dexter and Taryn and is that they come
so well prepared and so knowing where
they are and the story and that's how I
like to work so we come in and then
we've just got this playground where we
can create and play and and and try
different things so a lot of us on the
day just finding out what's going to be
our relationship for you I'm imagining
there's a lot of material to pull from
there's Elton there's all this different
stuff what was what was some key
research you did to get ready for the
role and there's not much here to prove
from that's what's interesting because
he's always in the background so there's
not interviews there's not even a lot of
pictures of him with Elton not a lot and
so he was quite hard to research you
know no interviews on YouTube things
like that so I had to ask a lot of
people I can defend try and pull stories
from people who'd worked with them or
know him or you know friends of hers
from a while ago so I kind of pulled all
these these different stories from
everyone tried to work out who the man
was it's so interesting and it also
plays into who he was mm-hmm you know
very very smart and ahead I
anyway what's a day that you're always
gonna remember from filming yeah a day
I'm always gonna remember from filming I
love being a mom Acosta's house that was
really cool he built this whole
situation in the forest and it was all
like beautiful lights and all these
vintage cars and it was a really fun day
actually so this your first time working
with deacons though yeah is there
anything you're looking for I mean he's
for me he's he's a genius he's like a
god I'm gonna [ __ ] working with some
Enders I just think he's okay standing
so I you know I'm kind of really excited
to see what we do is on well what is it
like for you right now there's a lot of
do you there's a lot of buzz about you
after body guard and with a lot of stuff
are you sort of paying attention to all
that do you feel that energy that's
bubbling up no I try to ignore all that
not look at the internet thing that's
very good you know I'm just focused and
on a train additional good work
environments with Rocketman my last
thing there's always deleted scenes was
there anything that didn't make the
final cut that you were disappointed and
not disappointed because I think the
films like beautifully edited and but
yeah the dance sequence I meant goes on
a little bit more after and I'm sure
that we in the DVD extras and that's
quite a fun sequence where it kind of it
takes another turn I understand I can't
wait to see it thank you so much for
your time and indulging my questions
thank you very much listen seriously
Congrats
thank you so much